we talked about benchmarks earlier so I
participated in machine learning didn't
really have a set of benchmarks I think
just two years ago they didn't have a
set of benchmarks and we've created
something called ml perf which is
machine learning benchmark suite and
pretty much the companies who didn't
invest in the software stack couldn't
run ml per very well and the ones who
did invest in software stack did and
we're seeing you know like kind of in
computer architecture this is what
happens you have these arguments about
risk versus ist's people spend billions
of dollars in the marketplace to see who
wins and it's not it's not a perfect
comparison but it kind of sorts things
out and we're seeing companies go out of
business and then companies like like
there's a company in Israel called
Habana they came up with machine
learning accelerators that they had good
ml perf scores Intel had acquired a
company earlier called Nirvana a couple
years ago they didn't reveal their
scores which was suspicious but a month
ago Intel announced they're cancelling
the Nirvana product line and they've
bought Habana for two billion dollars
and Intel's gonna be shipping Habano
chips which have hardware and software
and run the ml perf programs pretty well
and that's going to be their product
line in the future brilliant so maybe
just a linker briefly I'm a love metrics
I love standards that everyone can
gather around what are some interesting
aspects of that portfolio of metrics
well one of the interesting metrics is
you know what we thought it was you know
we I was involved in the start you know
we that Peter Matson is leading
different from Google Google got it off
the ground but we had to reach out to
competitors and say there's no
benchmarks here this we didn't we think
this is bad for the field it'll be much
better if we look at examples like in
the wrist days there was an effort to
create a for the the people in the risk
community got together competitors got
together a building risk Michael
processors to agree on a set of
benchmarks that we called spec and that
was good for the industry is rather
before the different risk architectures
were arguing well you can believe my
performance others but those other guys
are liars and that didn't do it
so we agreed on a set of benchmarks and
then we could figure out who was faster
between the various risk architectures
but it was a little bit faster but that
drew the market rather than you know
people were afraid to buy anything so we
argued the same thing would happen with
him Alper you know companies like Nvidia
were you know maybe worried that it was
some kind of trap but eventually we all
got together to create a set of
benchmarks and do the right thing right
and we agree on the results and so we
can see whether TP use or GPUs or CPUs
are really faster and how much the
faster and I think from an engineer's
perspective as long as the results are
fair Europe you can live with it ok you
know you can't tip your hat to to your
colleagues at another institution boy
they did a better job than this let's
see what you hate is if it's it's false
right they're making claims and it's
just marketing and you know and
it's affecting sales so you from an
engineer's perspective as long as it's a
fair comparison and we don't come in
first place that's too bad but it's fair
so we wanted to create that environment
for ML perf and so now there's 10
companies I mean 10 universities and 50
companies involved so pretty much AML
perf has is the it's the way you measure
machine learning performance and and it
didn't exist even two years ago one of
the cool things that I enjoy about the
Internet has a few downsides but one of
the nice things is people can see
through BS a little better with the
presence of metrics it's so it's really
nice a companies like Google and
Facebook and Twitter now it's the cool
thing to do is to put your engineers
forward and to actually show off how
well you do on these metrics there's not
sort of it well there's less of a desire
to do marketing a less so in my in my
sort of naive no I think well I was
trying to understand that you know
what's changed from the 80s in this era
I think because of things like social
networking Twitter and stuff like that
if you if you put up you know
stuff right that's just you know miss
purposely misleading you know that you
you can get a violent reaction in social
media pointing out the flaw
in your arguments right and so from a
marketing perspective you have to be
careful today that you didn't have to be
careful that there will be people who
put off the flaw you can get the word
out about the flaws and what you're
saying much more easily today than in
the past you used to be it was used to
be easier to get away with it and the
other thing that's been happening in
terms of serving off engineers is just
in the software side people have largely
embraced open-source software it it was
20 years ago it was a dirty word at
Microsoft and today Microsoft is one of
the big proponents of open source
software the kind of that's the standard
way most software gets built which
really shows off your engineers because
you can see if you look at the source
code you can see who are making the
commits who's making the improvements
who are the engineers at all these
companies who are are you know really
great programmers and engineers and
making really solid contributions which
enhances their reputations and the
reputation of the companies oh but
that's of course not everywhere like in
the space that I work more in is
autonomous vehicles and they're still
the machinery of hype and marketing is
still very strong there and there's less
willingness to be open in this kind of
open-source way and sort of benchmark so
ml per f is represents the machine
learning world is much better being open
source about holding itself to standards
of different the amount of incredible
benchmarks in terms of the different
computer vision eventually processing -
inaudible it you know historically it
wasn't always that way I had a graduate
student working with me David Martin so
for in computer in some fields
benchmarking is been around forever so
computer architecture databases maybe
operating systems benchmarks are the way
you measure progress but he was working
with me and then started working with
gender Malik and he's Jitender Malik and
in computer vision space who I guess
you've interviewed yes and Dave Martin
told me they don't have
benchmarks everybody has their own
vision algorithm in the way that my
here's my image look at how well I do
and everybody had their own image so
David Martin back when he did his
dissertation figured out a way to do
benchmarks he had a bunch of graduate
students identify images and then ran
benchmarks to see which algorithms run
well and that was as far as I know kind
of the first time people did benchmarks
in computer vision in which was predated
all you know the things that eventually
led to image net and stuff like that but
then you know the vision community got
religion and then once we got as far as
image net then that let the guys in
toronto be able to win the image net
competition and then you know that
changed the whole world the scary step
actually because when you enter the
world of benchmarks you actually have to
be good to participate as opposed to
yeah you can just you just believe
you're the best in the world and I think
the people I think they weren't
purposely misleading I think if you
don't have benchmarks I mean how do you
know you know you could have your
intuition it's kind of like the way we
did used to do computer architecture
your intuition is that this is the right
instruction set to do this job I believe
in my experience my hunch is that's true
we had to get to make things more
quantitative to make progress and so I
just don't know how you know in fields
that don't have benchmarks I don't
understand how they figure out how
they're making progress
you